that's the angle between a line
and the axis but we're interested in the
angle between two lines okay
so you're going to need to draw a new
cactus now you may remember
a little while back we were doing work
with the sine rule and the curse right
where we were
proving a bunch of things about it in
particular with the sine rule
we proved that make sure i write it
correctly a
on sine a is equal to b on sine b etc
but the reason why they're all equal to
each other is because does anyone
remember
why they're all equal to each other
it's because they're they're all equal
to something else outside of them
namely the diameter
of the second second that's right so so
you can write that as that
okay now when we did that we had to go
to some length and we went through three
cases we looked at
acute versions of the angle right angle
and the obtuse okay
now i could do the same thing with what
i'm about to do right now
okay but i'm just going to illustrate it
with one and i'll leave it to you to
have think about how i can apply it
when you have slightly different cases
okay so on here
let's draw two lines okay now on here
i'm interested in i should put a little
bracket here not just the angle between
two lines
but a specific one the acute one
okay because when you put up two lines
together unless they
meet at right angles one angle be acute
and one will be obtuse
okay now on the diagram that i have
drawn
the angle is there the acute angle okay
but depending on the way you've drawn it
perhaps it's actually this angle right
either one of them
could be the acute angle as you will see
these are the different cases that i was
talking about
but what we're going to establish works
with all of them okay
now that's that angle there in order to
sort of get from
one line at an angle to two i'm going to
need to know what their angles are
respectively okay so i'm going to call
this one over here
alpha okay so there's the first one uh
oops i should have named this one so it
matches up
so
you'll survive okay i'll call that one
alpha i'll call this one
beta in the corner okay
now i've got these lines labeled with
their equations which are
somewhat arbitrary to be honest i don't
know what they are it doesn't matter i
can still work with them even if i'm not
sure
now i want you to have a look at this
triangle um see how you have here
in this triangle here you have what we
call an exterior angle that's an
exterior angle right
outside the triangle and we know about
the relationship between the exterior
angle
and the two opposite interior angles
does anyone know what the relationship
is
here right now theta plus beta fantastic
whoops
okay they do rhyme are they theta beta
theta beta okay now
i've got that right but what i'm really
after is theta do you agree like that's
that's the angle between two lines okay
so just rearrange just a little bit
theta is equal to alpha minus beta
okay now here's where our pause and i'll
say there are other possibilities
in this case alpha is bigger than beta
right
so alpha will come first if i had two
other lines where
alpha was smaller than beta because that
would work too then this would be
switched around okay and if i go even
further
if if i just pick different angles maybe
this one's
almost vertical something like that it
could be 180 minus the sum of those okay
but i'm going to put to you that all of
those cases actually are equivalent
if you work them through okay so now
from there
the reason why this is useful is because
we now know
mass that can equip us to work out what
these things are
okay i'm going to take tan of both sides
tan theta equals 10
okay see that so
on the right hand side here i actually
know what this is equal to
because i have an identity that tells me
what it's equal to
right this is the difference identity
for tan okay
so if you can't remember it it's tan
alpha minus tan beta if i filled that in
i wonder if you can tell me the
denominator
one plus ten alpha ten b are fantastic
okay but from there i can even go a step
further
right because look here right if you
just forget about this second line for a
second you just look at this one here
m1x plus b1 and its angle is alpha
right for this guy here i can say that
tan
alpha is equal to what we just
established before for a single line
it's m1 isn't it right do you see that
that's its gradient
in exactly the same way i can say that
tan of beta
equals m2 right
so i can switch these guys in here i can
just say that's
m one minus m two all over
one plus m one m two
okay one last little step right i want
the acute angle between two lines the
acute angle right
so to make sure that i get the acute
angle
i have to ensure that i stay in this
quadrant you see that
right this is this is where 10 is
positive if i cross over here i'm in
trouble
i won't get the acute angle i'll get the
other one which is obtuse don't move
okay so to ensure that i get the
positive one
all i do is pulling back to first topic
slap absolute value signs around
everything okay because that will ensure
10 feet will be a positive number so
i'll automatically be in the first
quadrant i'll get the acute angle
okay so this here is the formula you can
use to find out whatever angle that is
for any combination of m1 or m2
okay